hello and welcome to the forest today i
thought i'd talk about something quite
vulnerable so i've gathered all of my
plants around me to help me through this
journey but basically a lot has changed
in my life recently and i've realized
that i had been thinking of myself and
thinking of my life in the wrong way i
found this one exercise which really
really helped me gain this clarity and i
thought
what the hell let's make a video out of
it because hopefully if you see your
life or existence in the way that i do
it might also be very very helpful i
wish i had seen this sooner so if this
sounds like that kind of thing you are
into
let's get straight into it but basically
not just now but for a while i've been
wondering if my life has been going in
the right direction and because so much
has changed i've started to question
things and am i reaching for the right
things and doing the right thing and
even though i absolutely do not have any
answers to what i'm supposed to be doing
i've done something which has helped me
so much be comfortable with what i
actually am doing and who i am and i
thought it was just too good to not
share the most important thing that this
exercise has given me is the realization
that most of my sadness in life actually
has been coming from things for which i
do not care about at all and they've
just been kind of like vestiges of who i
used to be as a person in the past i
never actually realized how much i
changed and now that i've done that in a
few minutes i honestly could let go of
so many sources of pain and sadness and
it has been like absolutely nothing else
that i've done in my life so i will be
linking the exercise in one of my free
notion pages in the description below
but if you feel like you want to hear
how i've used it and what it has done
for me you can't stick around so
basically for a bit of context what
prompted me to start this whole thing
was the fact that uh very recently i
made the decision to kind of leave
medical school which has been kind of
the center of my whole adult life has
been training to become a doctor and the
fact that my health was quite bad so i
had to
basically make the decision to drop off
for a while kind of threw me into this
sort of crisis and
for full context of course it is not the
end of the world that one kind of steps
away from their education for a while or
potentially forever for me it actually
did have a huge emotional effects on my
life it affected my own identity as a
person and who i potentially was it was
something difficult that i had to say to
my parents it had effects on my kind of
safe future that i'd imagined for myself
and been working for toward working
towards for so long and also it
potentially affected my career on this
youtube channel and my brand in general
so i think it was mainly that initial
thing that identity crisis of oh my god
what if i don't become a doctor or why
am i so attached to this thing that left
me on the path of trying to discover in
a bit more detail who i actually am and
who i think that i am and those two were
different things so the exercise that i
did was a values exercise and it might
seem quite lame at first glance but
please please please i challenge you to
take it seriously and do it in the
proper way because i can almost
guarantee that it will change your life
completely so basically what it is it is
a whole list of values and the first
thing i will say is please do this on
your own and don't show this to anyone
unless you actually want to because you
want to be completely honest with
yourself all of these values are
positive things such as acceptance from
other people or acceptance by yourself
or having money or having fame or being
safe or being secure or having like
financial stability so all of these
things are positive things and i guess
in an ideal world we would actually tick
all these boxes and have all of these
things but what you want to do for this
exercise is list them into things that
are important for you and things that
are not that important for you and the
way that i did it was actually taking it
a step further and focusing more on the
things that were surprisingly important
to me and things were which were
surprisingly unimportant for me so i'll
use some examples the first thing on the
list is acceptance so for me to be
accepted the way i am and even though
when i was younger this was a huge huge
value of mine i realized that now i
don't really care about this almost at
all i don't care to be accepted the way
i am by other people because i'm
actually comfortable with the way i am
and as long as i don't harm others which
i rarely do and i apologize when i do i
don't care to be liked so this is not
important to me at all the next one is
accuracy to be accurate in my opinions
and beliefs again couldn't care about it
less i am very very often wrong i'm very
open about my opinions and beliefs and
when they are wrong i'm happy to have my
mind changed i know that they change all
the time so it's not a strong value of
mine so i went down this whole list and
identified things that were important
and unimportant and then i narrowed it
down once more seeing the things that
were surprisingly important or
surprisingly unimportant for me and
this was the part that was absolutely
shocking even though i thought i kind of
knew myself i realized that the things
that were surprisingly unimportant to me
were the things that were bringing the
main source of stress and concern to my
life because i was living under the
assumption that i cared about these
things because i had cared about them at
some point in the past but the fact was
i actually never did and i could let go
of this dress so so fast for example uh
relating to my medical thing one of my
concerns with leaving medicine was
around safety and security for example
because i know that there have been many
times in my life where either me by
myself or me and my family have had very
little money and it always has been a
strong value of mine to have a stable
and secure life to be able to you know
pay rent and make the basic and have the
basic necessities of life however i
realize that this is no longer a value
of mine and i don't really care for it
as much and on the other hand i care
about things such as experiencing as
many things as possible in life having a
huge variety in the things that i do and
kind of being pushed about in life in a
positive way because i realize that the
main times that i've grown as a person
have actually been from experiences that
are quite you know emotionally mild if i
can say so so basically i realized that
safety and security was no longer on
that list and that concern that had been
brewing for a very long time with me
potentially you know risking my medical
career essentially disappeared because i
realized i don't care about this anymore
i love the phrase that we don't want to
go to our death beds or graves with a
kind of pristine well put together body
but we kind of want to be beat around by
life and have a lot of positive and
negative experiences and this is
something that i subscribe to as an
adult i just have to say caveat to this
because this is not a word of advice to
anyone else this is not even advice i
would give myself five years ago this is
not for 16 year olds or 18 year olds or
27 year olds who are in different
conditions i say this knowing that i
have quite a bit of training and that i
can go back to medical school and i can
do many other different like careers so
i know that i will be able to afford my
necessities so this is why i can take
this sort of risk in my case but this is
not advice to anyone else this is not me
telling anyone to kind of um subscribe
to one way or another this is a risk
that i take knowing that i am safe and
secure in my finances if that makes
sense so just had to say that to add to
that things like being flexible to new
conditions in life and me accepting
myself the way i am were very high on
the things that were surprisingly
valuable to me and this is not the way
that i had lived in the past so for
example i was quite
um shy to accept how nerdy i am or how
much into books i am or how much into
note-taking i am and now i realized i
don't actually care what other people
think about this and i find this thing
very fun no matter how nerdy it is so i
know this sounds really really small but
being able to accept this being able to
say that i want to be the kind of person
who can flexibly adapt to having to take
a break for something or change into
another career or be open about how they
feel about things online to thousands of
people is something that i value and the
kind of person i want to be and
therefore it gave me this kind of
permission and it gave me another layer
of acceptance and being able to do
things like this for example so i've
realized quite a lot with this exercise
it is surprisingly unimportant to me to
be a master in what i do or to be very
successful in what i do and this was
very surprising because when i was
younger this was one of my main core
values but i feel now as an adult
looking back on those times i realized
that i was excellent at what i did when
i was a child or a teenager but that did
not bring me joy i'm not happier right
now without caring about those things
and they might happen or they might not
happen but i genuinely couldn't care so
i feel as though that has been very very
liberating but something that i only
realized while doing this exercise to
have a purpose in life is something
surprisingly unimportant to me because
i've searched for that purpose for a
long time and i haven't found it and i
don't think it is something attainable
and realizing how much i've changed
means that my purpose will also
continuously change so i think it's
something that i don't really focus on
as much anymore and on the other hand
things that are surprisingly important
to me are taking risks and accepting
myself and having new experiences and
having intense friendships and having
different things happen in my life so
therefore i think through doing this
exercise i have got to know myself a lot
better i came to realize i had been
working with the same frameworks with
the same ways of thinking with the same
values that i had carried on from my
childhood despite me now becoming a
different person i'm more confident in
ways that i had never been before i'm
more accepting of myself in ways i had
never been before i care a lot less
about what people think something which
i had never done before and therefore
this has completely shaped the way that
i view my life and the way that i view
the world and not only this but there's
also been some other benefits with doing
this values exercise now i have this
list of two separate things so when i
get an opportunity or a decision to make
in life and i know that my gut instinct
may still come from that kind of pattern
of thinking which i've carried on for
all of my life but i can actually
compare it to my values and say hmm it's
not it's kind of against those that i
want to have or those that i currently
have and therefore it will not work or
therefore it will work in general i
don't use this on a day-to-day basis to
choose what i had for lunch when it
comes to huge decisions like going on a
holiday or not going on a holiday or
filming a risky video or not filming a
risky video it actually does help a lot
next thing that has helped me do is see
things in a different light risks or
loss are no longer a tragedy but just a
part of my constantly evolving life i
realize now that i'm a lot less dramatic
as an adult than i used to be as a child
and all of these bad things or terrible
things are actually quite interesting if
they are seen in a different light and
quite educational rather than something
to kind of be depressed and sad and
miserable about and the last thing which
is quite a big thing is realizing that
there's no single purpose to my life or
not one single value that i have but
actually this is a constantly evolving
thing and in a way i'm just kind of like
keeping up with my changing self rather
than setting this one certain goal and
aiming towards it because chances are
the goals that i would have had at the
age of 16 would be so different to the
goals that i want to have today and
therefore there is no purpose striving
for one like just one singular goal for
the rest of my life because even if i
get there i might find that i have
completely changed again and i am
completely miserable that's not to say
that i don't strive or don't want things
because i definitely do but the way that
i approach these things the anxieties
that i attach to them the amount of
desire that i want for these things is
massively different to the way that i
used to view them in the past so in the
end of the day i have realized that i
value having a messy hectic life quite a
bit i value having some level of
financial stability but beyond that i
value life keeping me on my toes and
challenging me in many different ways
and not having a stable singular kind of
path from point a to point b i value
embracing nerdy things that i genuinely
enjoy i value not attaching my value to
my career what i achieve or what i do i
value playing around with my own mind
what i think and how it changes and i
value trying to keep up with it i think
that all of these are likely to change
in the future and i genuinely don't mind
if they do i'm actually curious to see
what kind of person i become so i think
i might be doing this exercise maybe
twice a year or maybe once a year but
definitely once a year just to check in
and see how i feel about things because
generally the clarity it has given me is
like nothing else one value that i'm
actually fairly confident will stick
with me for the rest of my life is that
of lifelong education and on that note i
want to give a huge huge thank you to
curiositystream for sponsoring me on
this video josie stream is the place
where i like to guiltlessly relax with
nature documentaries which are so so
calm i remind myself of phil from modern
family just putting my headphones on
just listening to nature's sounds and
nature documentaries but what i'm
currently watching are these episodes on
redesign my brain i'm currently on
episode one which is making you smarter
which reminds me of that movie i don't
know what it's called where this guy
takes a pill and then he becomes
ridiculously intelligent this is more
like the
scientifically
literate version of that movie but yes
curiosity stream is actually incredibly
reasonably priced and beyond that you
also get access to nebula which is where
other creators and myself will post our
youtube videos where you can watch them
for an ad free experience and if you
want access to both of these i have a
great discount link in my description
but yes that was everything i had to say
in this quite rambly video about values
in general i have quite a few different
frameworks that i've used to
redesign the way that i think about
myself and i go back to them again and
again so there is more where this came
from if this made any sort of sense to
you please let me know i would love to
chat about things like this some more
and my notion page will be linked in the
description let me know if you find it
helpful and otherwise if you made it so
far thank you so much for spending this
time with me i hope you have a wonderful
rest of your day be kind yourself and
others and everything you think thanks
bye